the crisis at the southern border from
Casey's reporting you know will add this
to it
it's taking a different kind of toll our
men and women who protect our nation's
sovereignty are challenged we know that
so much against them so much to deal
with well now we're learning some of
them are really hurting
three border patrol agents committed
suicide in November that same month that
we saw that onslaught of people who just
evaded every means to catch them
14 have committed suicide in total in
2022
House Republicans have introduced a bill
to provide more Mental Health Resources
for the Department they're proposing
nearly 140 million dollars over six
years to tackle the issue Republican
senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
ranking member of the budget committee
also member of the Judiciary and
Appropriations committees is in Focus
now Senator welcome
this situation now is starting to mirror
what we know happens when there's
pressure on our police departments when
there's pressure on our military your
thoughts
well if you're a border patrol agent you
feel abandoned by the body
Administration I've been to the border
patrol border many times I don't know
how they go home at night and get up the
next day they're seeing human
trafficking at a level I've never seen
they're overwhelmed with illegal
immigrants coming in people on the
terrorist watch list are going right
through so to be a border patrol agent
under Biden is one of the most miserable
experiences I can imagine to be in
charge of protecting America and the
administration you work for will not
give you the tools to do your job is
very bad for morale so it's just a
matter of time until somebody comes
across that border that kills a bunch of
Americans because they're terrorists the
number of Americans dying from fentanyl
poisoning is at an all-time high Biden
has surrendered the border and those in
charge are protecting us at the border
feel completely abandoned and I hope our
House Republicans will start hearings
and will put on the table impeaching
people responsible for this well I tell
you those are some heart-shaking words
that you just spoke Biden has
surrendered the border and what will we
see in next steps in terms of the damage
that that can cause
you're going to see an increased number
of illegal drugs coming in particularly
fentanyl that will kill more and more
Americans you're going to see pressure
on Border communities where they for the
community collapses under the weight
it's just a matter of time that
terrorists that are rising in
Afghanistan and Syria will make their
way through the border to attack us
their desire to attack us hasn't stopped
we basically have a welcome mat at the
border for for terrorists if they want
to come into the country and there's no
corrective action the Asylum system is
broken people the gotaways for every
guide away there are three or four
people coming to say here I am yes uh
capture me and that's the problem if you
get one foot in America you're likely
never going to leave under our Asylum
program they did they undid everything
that Trump did the bite Administration
took all the border security measures of
the Trump Administration and changed
them overnight and if you do away we'll
title 42 Authority which will happen in
a few weeks is throwing gasoline on a
fire wow you said a Welcome Matt the
godaways aren't interested in being
welcomed in fact they seem to and
haven't been down there just a few weeks
ago I was standing in one of the places
that they come through we just don't
have enough people to catch them even if
we wanted to so we see them coming in
those are the ones who are willing to be
caught on camera you know they figured
some things out they're wearing
camouflage and coming mostly at night
now I mean it's it's unreal I I want to
move to this it's the final Sprint in
the high stakes Georgia Senate runoff
and more than one million voters there
have already early voted in the runoff
new polling shows a squeaker of a race
right now Democrat Senator Rafael
Warnock with a slight Edge over football
icon Herschel Walker 51 to 47 percent at
this point Warnock turning to his
political party's heaviest hitters
Barack Obama you see there
and with the Democrat and Atlanta last
night there are many more who were
expected to come
and Obama took this jab at Herschel
Walker
I believe in my soul that Georgia knows
that Georgia is better than Herschel
Walker when again and again you serve up
bald-faced lives just make stuff up
that says something about the kind of
person you are
and the kind of leader you would be if
you were in the United States Senate
Senator Graham your reaction
Herschel Walker is going to win this
race I just got briefed by The Campaign
on their latest poll you're going to
have about 72 percent of the people that
voted in the general election are going
to vote in the runoff there's going to
be a 28 percent drop so I like
herschel's chances this race is tied
they spent 170 million dollars trying to
destroy Herschel Walker and the race is
tied and I think the wind is herschel's
back Warnock has been with by 96 percent
of the time if you're looking for a new
senator from Georgia to act differently
uh in Washington then you better elect
Walker not Warnock 96 percent of the
time he's been uh with Biden he has
surrendered our border Biden has and
warnick's done nothing to take it back
he's voted for every High tax bill there
is the amount of money coming against
Herschel Walkers the most in the history
of the United States since a lot they're
trying to destroy him go to go to
teamhearschel.com and if the May
millions of people watching would give a
few bucks we could close that Gap we're
in 72-hour mode right here trying to
turn out the voter they're spending 17
more in million in super Pacs 17 million
more in ground game help us
teammercial.com here's the bottom line
we're three days away and Herschel is
still tied and I think he's going to win
that's what I was going to ask I mean
that's that's a lot of of resource
that's a lot of men and women power
that's a lot going on on the on the left
side of the aisle and they still are
within a statistical tie
you mentioned being on the ground and I
know we've seen you you've been with
Herschel Walker I I don't know if you
saw someone moved to Georgia right it's
a beautiful state I was born there
um the bitter race now is focusing on
character
and that same survey shows what voters
over 50 really care about inflation and
looming threats to democracy Walker has
a major Edge in that older demographic
and I want to get to this
there's some
inequality in the Press coverage a
recent analysis by a conservative media
Watchdog found broadcast network gave
Herschel Walker 88 percent negative
coverage compared with 71 percent
positive coverage for Warnock are you
seeing some of that when when you kind
of take temporary residency there trying
to help them out senator
number one you can't turn on the
television without seeing five ads for
worn out to one of Herschel and the
bottom line they're trying to destroy
Herschel Walker as a person because he's
an African-American conservative he won
the Heisman Trophy he played
professional football he was on the
Olympic Bob Bob said bobsled team he's
created thousands jobs in Georgia he's
an entrepreneur and he danced for the
New York ballet I've never met anybody
quite like Kershaw Walker if he becomes
the Republican senator from Georgia he's
going to inspire people of color all
over the country to come to the to the
Republican conservative calls that's why
they're trying to destroy him you know
why they're doing all this because they
know they're losing ground to Herschel
Herschel can win this race let's close
the gap go to Team herschel.com if you
want people uh on the conservative side
to look more like America when people
like Kershaw comes along we need to help
them please go to teamhercial.com five
or ten bucks goes a long way the reason
they're trying to go down the character
Road the policy 0 doesn't work Georgia
has a 59 percent disapproval rating of
Joe Biden The Walker Kim the the Warnock
campaign asked Joe Biden to help you
know where he went they want him to go
to Massachusetts to help Warnick in
Georgia I want him to come to Georgia to
help Warnick Walker wants Biden in
Georgia Warnick wants him in
Massachusetts Warnick is the third
senator from Massachusetts you can't
even make that up in fact when the
president was wrapping up his signings
just moments ago to in the uh to thwart
the rail strike people were shouting
questions you know from the media and he
he decided to answer one of them are you
going to to Georgia to help Herschel
Walker did you hear what he said well
yeah and then he said well no I'm going
to Massachusetts to help Herschel Walker
and I thought
but Herschel Walker's in Georgia who
wants to tell him but he knows and you
just said why
well because he's aligned with the
voting records of Massachusetts not
Georgia the bottom line here is the
reason they're sending buying to
Massachusetts that's where all the
Liberals money is at we're being
outspent three to one teammerschel.com
but I think God that the leader of the
democratic party is being asked to go to
Massachusetts to win a race in Georgia
because if Biden came to Georgia it'd be
pretty obvious to people in Georgia that
they don't want Biden here because they
don't like what he's doing as president
and Warnick has been with by 96 percent
of the time that's why he's in
Massachusetts not Georgia and I misspoke
of course he's going to help Warnock
from Massachusetts some kind of way from
Massachusetts
it's also a beautiful state it just
doesn't actually have the Georgia Senate
runoff going on in Massachusetts the
president wanting to help warn up from a
distance a lot of Democrats felt that
way during the midterms help them from a
distance Senator Graham thank you very
much appreciate you being in Focus
thanks so much